Дрезден - дуже популярне серед туристів місто
столиця землі Саксонія
А ще оплот правопопулістської партії
Альтернатива для Німеччини
Їй не потрібно було вести тут активну агітацію, щоб перемогти
Три роки тому АдН увійшла
до земельного парламенту цієї федеральної землі
а тепер - лідирувала у цій же землі також і на виборах до Бундестагу
Звісно, це насамперед чіткий сигнал Саксонії
що ми незадоволені політикою пані Меркель
та великої коаліції і прагнемо змін
Але це також і великий виклик для АдН
представляти такі погляди наших виборців у Бундестазі
і забезпечити там альтернативну політику
Антиісламський рух «Пегіда» - союзник АдН
Вони традиційно вийшли на демонстрацію
перед відомим дрезденським собором Фрауенкірхе
Після виборів до Бундестагу мітингувальники
у захваті від результатів АдН
Я радий, що в Бундестазі
нарешті буде представлена справжня опозиція
Те, що будо досі, не можна назвати опозицією
Зупинити незаконну масову імміграцію
вислати всіх тих, хто нелегально в’їхав, покарати канцлерку
яка порушила закони цієї країни
Хтось мусить брати на себе ініціативу
Адже нічого ж не змінювалося
Політикою пані Меркель всі ми незадоволені
Нарешті в Бундестазі знову опозиція
яка реально чинитиме опозицію
«Пегіда» називає Дрезден
столицею опору політиці Меркель
Тепер праві популісти з ксенофобськими поглядами
отримали голос у німецькому парламенті